es uno de los países más recónditos
perdidos y desconocidos que existen una
prueba os hago tres preguntas
alguna vez has escuchado hablar de un cx
tan sabría situarlo exactamente en un
mapa y la tercera podrías decirme cuál
es su capital si ha respondido bien a
las tres preguntas enhorabuena eres todo
un experto en geografía internacional si
no es así no te preocupes es lo más
normal y hoy vas a tener la oportunidad
de descubrir muchas cosas porque amigos
hoy en visual político hablamos de
uzbekistán
[Aplausos]
[Música]
puede que no sea muy popular pero con
más de 30 millones de habitantes
uzbekistán es el país más poblado de
asia central y es un país súper joven en
los dos sentidos no sólo porque uno de
cada tres habitantes tenga menos de 14
años sino también porque el país formaba
parte de la unión soviética así que como
país moderno e independiente uzbekistán
apenas tiene 28 28 añitos y amigos es un
país remoto uzbekistán está tan aislado
del resto del mundo que no es que no
tenga salida al mar sino que junto a
liechtenstein es el único país de todo
el planeta que está rodeado por países
que tampoco tienen salida al mar y desde
luego sus vecinos no es que sean mis
popularidad kirguistán tayikistán
türkmenistán kazajistán y afganistán
este último sí es muy conocido aunque no
para bien en fin ya lo veis si queréis
vivir en pleno siglo 21 una aventura
propia de todo un explorador alejados
del mundo conocido y sentiros como
richard kapucinski david livingstone o
incluso porque no marcopolo entonces
este puede ser un buen de estilo pero
amigos evidentemente este no es un
anuncio de viajes así que os hago una
pregunta por qué diantres pensáis que en
visual política hablamos de uzbekistán
alguna idea que os parece si os digo que
este país está en plena encrucijada
[Música]
fijaos uzbekistán un país del tamaño de
california pero con tan sólo el 15 por
ciento del pib californiano un país
donde apenas uno de cada tres habitantes
vive en las ciudades tiene que tomar una
importante decisión lanzarse a un
programa completo de reformas que lo
pongan de una vez por todas rumbo a
convertirse en una economía del siglo 21
o por el contrario volverá a cerrarse y
desaparecer para el resto del mundo y
que queréis que os diga este tipo de
cosas en visual político nos encantan en
este vídeo vamos a ver qué está
ocurriendo en uzbekistán pero antes
antes tenemos que conocer a un personaje
os suena el nombre de islam karímov
atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mano dura bolsillo lleno
amigos hay ocasiones donde todo cambia
para que en el fondo las cosas sigan
prácticamente igual y eso es
precisamente lo que pasó en uzbekistán
cuando en 1991 este país declaró su
independencia de la desmoronada unión
soviética
en ese momento este hombre que estáis
viendo islám karímov era el secretario
general del partido comunista en
uzbekistán y al mismo tiempo el
presidente de la república socialista
soviética uzbeka sí claro sí tenía el
poder en sus manos para que soltarlo esa
es la cuestión que debió hacerse el
propio karímov que por supuesto decidió
no hacerlo
[Música]
el día 1 de septiembre de 1991 cuando
aún no estaba del todo claro que la
unión soviética terminará por
desintegrarse karim o vio clara la
jugada y declaró la independencia de
uzbekistán el 29 de diciembre de ese
mismo año se celebraron unas elecciones
unas elecciones tan fraudulentas que
hasta el mismísimo nicolás maduro
parecería a nelson mandela
karímov se hizo con el 88 por ciento de
los votos ya partir de ahí
sorprendentemente nunca ha bajado el
porcentaje de votos
karímov sabía cómo mantener el
porcentaje de votos total le bastaba con
hacer una llamada a la junta electoral y
dictarles el resultado de las elecciones
antes incluso de que se celebraran ya
está con esto ya era más que suficiente
para ganar todas las elecciones del
mundo
[Música]
el caso amigos es que durante sus 25
largos años en el poder
islam karímov se convirtió en el amo y
señor de uzbekistán uno de los tiranos
más despreciados del planeta un tipo
capaz de decir algo así públicamente
atentos estoy preparado para arrancar
las cabezas de 200 personas con el fin
de salvar la paz y la calma en la
repubblica islam karímov en un ex radio
karímov supervisó abusos de derechos
humanos realmente terribles durante sus
más de 25 años como presidente de
uzbekistán
williamson the human rights watch
[Música]
durante sus años en el poder la censura
de los medios de comunicación fue una de
las más estrictas de todo el planeta
las detenciones y condenas a periodistas
y activistas sociales y políticos fueron
continuas la policía y los servicios
secretos utilizaban la tortura como
parte del protocolo habitual
[Música]
y el resultado es que por supuesto en
uzbekistán nadie se atrevía a hablar mal
del presidente además kerímov utilizó la
expropiación como un mecanismo habitual
para consolidar su poder sí lo siento
aquí hugo chávez tampoco fue un gran
innovador más bien un aprendiz y
preservó un montón de políticas
económicas que aprendió durante la etapa
soviética políticas como controles de
divisas tasas oficiales de cambio
completamente artificiales un papel
enorme del estado en la economía
etcétera etcétera para colmo a pesar de
estar tan aislado se llevaba fatal con
la mayoría de sus vecinos todo esto es
lo que explica que bajo su mandato la
mayoría de la población fuese pobre muy
pobre a pesar de que uzbekistán es un
país muy rico en hidrocarburos y en
recursos minerales por ejemplo las
terceras mayores reservas de oro de todo
el planeta están aquí
por cierto no os podemos dar el
porcentaje exacto de pobreza porque
formalmente el gobierno uzbeko determinó
por ley que en el país no existe la
pobreza y si no existe pues no se mide
eso sí para que os hagáis una idea
pensad que el salario medio de 225
dólares mensuales en los empleos
formales en los informales es aún más
bajo
mientras tanto como fácilmente podéis
imaginar la familia y el círculo de
karímov acumularon una inmensa fortuna
las propias hijas de karímov se han
paseado por los lugares más glamurosos
del mundo han compartido vivencias con
las grandes estrellas de hollywood han
sacado discos líneas de joyas perfumes
todo lo que les hiciera gracia pero
amigos tal vez donde mejor podamos ver
lo inmensamente tirano despótico
autócrata que era el gobierno de karímov
es echando un vistazo a lo que ocurría
en el sector del algodón
tradicionalmente la actividad económica
más importante del país
[Música]
y sus x tangas uno de los mayores
productores de algodón del mundo
el caso es que podéis imaginar un país
donde cada año el líder esclaviza a un
porcentaje muy importante de la
población para que trabajen para él y no
seáis mal pensados en esta ocasión no
estamos hablando de los impuestos sino
de trabajo forzoso
pues eso es exactamente lo que ocurría
en uzbekistán
y así es cada año entre septiembre y
noviembre para recoger la cosecha de
algodón el gobierno movilizaba entre 1 y
2 millones de personas en condiciones
prácticamente de esclavitud para
librarse de ir tenías que enviar a otra
persona o atenerse a las consecuencias
la mayor parte eran trabajadores
públicos como médicos o profesores o
trabajadores de empresas que trabajaban
para el gobierno si lo habéis escuchado
bien de hecho por ejemplo un montón de
hospitales se quedaban prácticamente sin
médicos porque el gobierno les enviaba a
recoger algodón vienes al trabajo todo
preparado vistiendo ropa bonita buenos
zapatos y él
todos del policlínico corre y te dice
necesito a 40 personas en el campo el
autobús está afuera apúrate apúrate el
algodón es obligatorio para todos el
gobierno da las órdenes y tú no puedes
ir en contra de esas órdenes si me niego
me despedirán perderíamos el pan que
comemos y no sólo eso gran parte de
estos trabajadores forzados durante
muchos años fueron niños que tenían que
dejar de ir al colegio para recoger
algodón para el gobierno
[Música]
y es que amigos el sistema era el
siguiente los agricultores recibían mano
de obra gratis y luego le vendían el
algodón al gobierno a un precio por los
suelos luego el gobierno era quien se lo
vendía a las empresas textiles sólo
exportaba para producir ropa a lo largo
y ancho del mundo a un precio muchísimo
mayor del que había pagado a los
agricultores de ahí que el algodón se
convirtiera en una de las mayores
fuentes de ingresos del gobierno en fin
ya lo veis karímov no se andaba con
chiquitas
tal vez otro ejemplo de lo despótico y
autoritario que era karim o lo podemos
encontrar en cómo trató a su propia hija
veréis karímova era por así decirlo la
hija favorita incluso se especulaba que
sería su heredero
diría a todo trapo como una artista de
hip hop en un viernes por la tarde y era
muy popular entre la jet-set mundial si
había una fiesta o un festival que
mereciera la pena en cualquier parte del
planeta
ahí estaba karímova entre otras cosas
llegó a ser la embajadora de uzbekistán
en españa'
pues bien lo cierto es que karímova le
causó algún que otro problemilla al
gobierno porque ni corta ni perezosa
había estafado cientos de millones de
dólares a compañías internacionales a
cambio de falsas concesiones en
uzbekistán y luego para colmo discutió y
se enfrentó públicamente con su madre y
con su hermana y claro eso ya fue
demasiado vamos a ver lo de las
multinacionales y los millones de
dólares pues pase pero oye con la
familia no se discute así que un buen
día karímov envió a la policía secreta a
casa de su hija con un operativo propio
de película de hollywood
[Música]
imaginaos unos soldados vestidos de
negro que asaltaban la casa de karímova
lanzándose con cuerdas desde
helicópteros la detuvieron y la
encerraron en una habitación de una
mansión karímova una de las mujeres más
ricas del mundo no volvió a ver a su
padre y nadie la ha vuelto a ver a ella
recientemente se ha sabido que la han
trasladado a una prisión uzbeka y el
juicio que la condenó se celebró en su
propia cocina tal cual como lo oís en
otras palabras que karímov no se andaba
con chiquitas
[Música]
sorprendidos bueno pues a pesar de todo
ello ojo porque karim o fue un buen
aliado de occidente especialmente de los
eeuu si lo habéis escuchado bien pero un
momento stop como pueden los países
occidentales ser aliados de semejante
tirano
[Música]
bueno digamos que había dos motivos de
peso veréis por un lado uzbekistán es un
país mayoritariamente musulmán pero el
gobierno de karímov se oponía con todas
sus fuerzas al islamismo radical y lo
perseguía con la misma mano dura con la
que mantenía sometido a su pueblo bueno
incluso con más mano dura evidentemente
no lo hacía por convicción o por
defender las libertades o la tolerancia
sino porque le suponía una clara amenaza
para su poder por otro lado uzbekistán
tiene frontera con afganistán y eso es
algo que a los eeuu tras la invasión de
afganistán le vino muy bien
de hecho el pentã gono instaló una base
aérea en el sur del país eso sí a cambio
de regar de dinero al régimen de karímov
sólo en 2002 el gobierno uzbeko recibió
500 millones de dólares cosas de la
política internacional en fin pero
amigos en 2016 con la muerte de karímov
todo esto llegó a su fin y ahora la
pregunta es ha comenzado realmente una
nueva era atentos
[Música]
el cambio no cambió
presta atención a esta noticia
uzbekistán emerge del aislamiento con la
venta de mil millones de dólares en
bonos
[Aplausos]
en febrero del 2019 el gobierno de
uzbekistán hizo su primera emisión de
bonos en el mercado internacional
emitiendo en londres euro bonos por
valor de 1000 millones de dólares y
sabéis que los inversores
internacionales se los quitaron de las
manos la demanda fue ocho veces mayor
que la oferta y la pregunta es qué
inversor en su sano juicio le prestaría
dinero a un gobierno como éste
[Música]
pues queridos amigos de visual político
el caso es que tras la muerte de karim o
subió a la presidencia su 'número dos'
el primer ministro shahbaz mirziyóyev
del que todo el mundo esperaba que
siguiera los pasos de su predecesor al
fin y al cabo era su primer ministro
sin embargo para sorpresa general mills
dijo jeff anunció un montón de reformas
para abrir el país al mundo entero por
ejemplo mejora las relaciones con sus
vecinos prohibió el trabajo forzoso en
la cosecha del algodón y purgó a los
altos mandos de los servicios de
seguridad que habían liderado la
represión
la parte liberó a un montón de presos
políticos y sacó a 18.000 personas de
una lista negra del gobierno que les
impedía viajar o poder trabajar tan solo
la mejora de las relaciones con sus
vecinos y la reapertura de los pasos
fronterizos ha hecho que el comercio de
uzbekistán con el resto de países de
asia central se haya incrementado en un
50 por ciento desde el año 2017 es decir
en apenas dos años
[Música]
sí
y esperad un momento porque ahí no
termina todo con mucha diferencia donde
más cambios se han producido ha sido en
la política económica el nuevo gobierno
ha eliminado los controles de capitales
y gran parte de los controles de precios
ha anunciado la privatización de la
mayoría de las empresas públicas han
reducido los aranceles y le han dado vía
libre a las empresas sus becas para que
exporten sin tener que pedirle permiso
al gobierno ni tener que pagarle
también han anunciado impuestos más
bajos para los uzbekos y sobre todo para
las empresas que inviertan en el país
vamos todo lo contrario de lo que al
final ha terminado haciendo mauricio
macri presidente macri que le tenga que
dar lecciones el presidente de
uzbekistán de la marinera
[Música]
incluso como los funcionarios del país
han sido tradicionalmente muy corruptos
el ministro de hacienda el señor kucarov
ha decretado una moratoria de tres años
en todas las inspecciones a las empresas
mientras el gobierno mejora sus procesos
y reduce la burocracia curioso
[Música]
el caso amigos es que son todos estos
motivos los que han hecho que los
pronósticos sobre el futuro del país
hayan mejorado tanto que el gobierno
público ahora puede emitir deuda en
londres sin que los inversores salgan
corriendo ahora bien quiere decir esto
que uzbekistán se ha transformado por
completo pues no para nada
veréis uzbekistán aunque mejor que con
karímov sigue siendo un país con un
gobierno represor sigue existiendo la
censura y todavía no se vislumbra ni por
asomo elecciones libres y por supuesto
el presidente tiene un control enorme
sobre todo lo que pasa en este país
digamos que el proceso acaba de comenzar
si es que realmente ha comenzado pero
amigos eso sólo lo podremos ver con el
tiempo y desde luego en visual política
estaremos muy pero que muy atentos
porque no me digáis que esta no es una
historia súper interesante de hecho creo
que este ha sido un vídeo 100% visual
político así que amigos ya lo sabéis si
queréis seguir conociendo qué ocurre en
el mundo no olvidéis suscribiros al
canal y por supuesto si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante darle al like un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]